we got this one from fox news black
lives matter protesters rally for a
victim
leave after learning he was white the
original story reported was that they
left when they learned he was a
carjacker i read that and i was like
hold on a minute the the dante right
dude he was a
wanted for aggravated robbery the crime
committed is not
the reason they're supporting or
opposing the individual so the word
breaks
that some dude was killed by the cops
everybody takes a knee and they're
protesting and then someone's like wait
wait hold on
he's a white dude and then all of a
sudden i was like ah and they all leave
yeah so they i don't think they really
care about police brutality
i think they that's a good point yeah
the issue is is it a popular narrative
well
yeah exactly i mean i think basically
when you say that they don't have an
ideology their ideology is to be
oppositional
to that which you know they've been
taught to think is wrong which is like
it's a very specific set of truths it's
tribalism
exactly and the reason i say that sorry
to interrupt is that
if if we were gonna say it's about black
lives matter and they don't there is not
concern about the white guys because
the race issue then they wouldn't have
been making fun of asian people for
years
only to now change and act like they
care about asian people there's no real
ideology it's just whatever the tribe
is focused on now and it happens to be
black lives matter
it's grifton season well i mean by the
way like
the reason why i got into media is cause
like during the 2003 invasion
of iraq it everybody was for the war in
iraq including cnn msnbc because
it was politically incorrect not to be
pro-military which
that manifested itself in better before
the war or else and so like if you look
back to the news coverage of that
you would have expected those networks
you know to be oh well george bush wants
to do this and it's terrible
no no not at all and think about the
amount of human suffering that resulted
from that i mean
where where are the who's asking the
media professionals who said that
we should go into iraq they get away
with all of it
so i think mostly what you see these
people the reason why they would say
walk away from a protest when they find
out the guy's white is because
it's just whatever the popular media
narrative is they're getting their cues
they're being told to do
bill maher had this really amazing
segment where he almost got it
it was hilarious where he was like
sensationalist negative news coverage
about covet is making democrats
insane so there was a poll done new york
times published this
asking democrats republicans and
independents
the the likelihood of hospitalization
for coven what they thought it was
more than 50 percent i think 75 percent
of democrats got it wrong
and republicans got 26 republicans were
correct
and most of them got it wrong as well
but substantially less than democrats
and then 20
of independents and so bill maher's like
the media that democrats consume is
constantly negative and it's making them
crazy
but donald trump is bad that was true
that was all true
it's like okay dude's probably lying so
here's what happens you get people who
are sitting there bored with no purpose
and the media is like what can we say to
manipulate people into giving us money
and getting us ad clicks
fear porn is that fear boom yup exactly
extrapolate that same thing to the right
which is like people's perception is one
thing you know just sitting in in their
homes
and then all of a sudden it's like wait
a second you're telling me that
these aren't it's not a party-like
atmosphere and it's a and it's a and
then the thing is what they'll do is
like cnn or msnbc is you you'll watch
the news
segment and you get you get fed that
fear porn and as soon as the commercials
hit
hey here's those paintings for your back
exactly dude
a right for you ask your doctor side
effects maybe you didn't even tell me
what the drug does
what it does you're watching that's an
amazing point you're watching cnn you're
watching fox or whatever
and they're like there are people's
homes being burned down
children fired upon now we'll be back
after these messages
and then the drug commercials yeah like
if you're watching might as well be a
cigarette
shaking like smoking yeah you'll be
watching fox's sean hannity then after
that goes commercial it'll be larry
elder he'll be like hey does your back
hurt like mine
pop these pills then the next commercial
be like hey did you take those pills
well
you might be you might get a
conversation that's the point they're
both selling they're both hocking the
same products on
on each side yeah and all that matters
is you just you just say to that
corporate
that party line as long as corporate
america is down with it
you're good to go i don't know i don't
know i got i will stop though and i i
think bret baer and tucker carlson do a
good job
i think tucker leans but what happens to
those guys what happens to tucker
carlson
well i i went on tucker to say what i
saw in kenosha
right yeah and all i said was
rittenhouse told me this
i saw this and then cnn says mcginnis
supported the conservative claim that
written house acted in self-defense and
i said
i emailed him um okay you either
that's a misstatement that's that's
either had me on to correct the record
or
prepare for court they held me on to
correct the record and they did good
journalism after that but
that's how it works they corrected it
they had me back on and they did a
longer segment with me yeah they did oh
that's cool yeah to their credit but i
just had it you know
i wouldn't have gotten on if i hadn't
literally threatened that
i'm not a big fan of fox news as a whole
but brett bear does a really good job
he's a great reporter and tucker carlson
leans into tribalism every so often
but he does i think tend to do a pretty
good job however i'm not a big fan
of ingram or hannity uh i like kill me
is doing a new thing recently i talked
to him i thought he doesn't okay i think
regardless it's like
let those ideas be exposed to the
sunlight and
let them die there rather than okay who
is it who advertise on this program okay
you guys all advertise do you support
this specific statement that they said
this one time
otherwise you're done and that's but
listen there's no free speech anymore
cable news
there's fox news and then there's
literally every other network yep and so
fox yes
in my opinion not great individuals but
like i think greg gutfeld and the five
yeah do a really good job and i i really
i i am a fan of juan williams or at
least
on fox news is the the anchors could
also have different ideologies
on cnn yes cnn is like hey guys this is
the track
you guys don't run it and i think one
thing that really opened my not not
opened my eyes but i think it was a good
moment for the american people to see
was
when tucker carlson he was coming to the
end of his segment and it was when he
was bashing
amazon and jeff bezos and then he's
handing it off to sean hannity and you
can hear
sean hannity obviously he's hearing
tucker then he goes oh we've we support
free market and capitalism you just see
tucker do that face
yeah yeah and i thought that was
actually a great moment for fox because
it shows hey we could at least differ on
these things
be on the same network but it was by
mistake
hold on this is why i said i'm a fan of
juan williams because he he
like they they rag on him yeah i think
he's wrong
all the time like i'm sitting there
watching jesse laugh at him and i'm like
juan is
wrong but i'm glad that he's willing to
be there with them
taking that punishment and and and
saying what he believes with passion
some people think he fakes it i'm like
no the dude genuinely believes i think
that's the point though is
if if you appear on either of these two
echo chambers
then you are this so right i was trying
to tell the american public one thing
what i saw
and it was an incredible challenge for
me to navigate the landscape
after the shooting because i had to
basically i appeared on fox first
okay you're this and it's like no no
that's a misstatement hear the facts
prepare for court
or have me on i mean i i say
i say like got a threat you gotta
threaten i say a bunch of wacky stuff on
this show
but will the grifters on twitter ever
take the clips of me saying tax the rich
or police exactly you should resign they
won't do that they'll take the clips
that are like kylo ren's acted in
self-defense
and then they'll tell everyone on the
left tim poole is far right or whatever
and then the people who actually watch
the show are like tim's a liberal all
right tim i have to say when you
i'd agree or i agree i'd say i don't
know what you're being surprised or not
now
i know you've been doing this just like
i don't know what what would you call it
but i know when you're kind of sarcastic
but this is called gaslighting
hold on hold on i have i have
consistently and always said i'm in
favor of a higher progressive tax
tax on yeah no that is true always
always and the reason i tweeted it
is because i was like i finally started
to notice and i never i never really
cared that much and i was like oh you
know what's happening
these these the manipulation machine the
media machine needs an enemy they need
to make money off this so they
purposefully watch the show and ignore
all of like the normal like kind of
liberal positions they might hold
and then look for that one thing that's
kind of conservative yeah and then they
take that and they put it on top
that's i was on a reality tv show
actually um
it was not very watched but it was 2016
called them it was called
house divided it was on full screen
media i think they scrubbed it
after hillary lost it was a big uh i
don't need to go there
but basically you sign a contract where
you can basically sign everything away
like it's like we can repurpose your
content for whatever to portray you as
whatever we want
so i went in there and i'm like you know
i'm uh
across the board you can't really put my
politics in a box very easily
and so i said you know i'd be a
libertarian who supports a lot of
kind of you know big government efforts
to even the playing field but that
doesn't fit in a box right so
i said oh they'd say what do you think
about this well the conservat
conservative movement blah blah blah oh
what are your politics i'm uh
like on camera in my interview then cut
to b-roll and then cut to
me saying conservative in a different
instance conservative they did that
oh yeah yeah what do you think of this
girl oh she's really she's pretty she's
super nice
uh what do you think about the weather
outside it was super hot outside oh
she's
cut to b-roll hot so like i'm telling
you like no seriously in my contract
there's no recourse because the contract
you sign you sign it away
so by the way please everybody out there
don't go look this show up because
that's really bad what was the show
called again it's called
divided but it's like it just goes to
show how you can just take
p you say enough words you're on camera
for eight hours a day
they can choose whatever they want and
then use the power of editing to just
oh yeah portray whatever they want i
love it when there was one clip that
went viral of me where there was literal
jump cuts like
and because i was issuing caveats i was
like here's what i think
now keep in mind a b and c one two three
but with that said exactly
they cut out all the cabinets so it's
like me going like i think that donald
trump is the greatest
present ever joe biden is the worst
what's that what's that said like people
were putting like famous people they're
like they'll be singing the song like a
d fake that scared the crap out of me
that's that's i
think we're having oh yeah yeah take a
picture of you and make it dance yeah
that
was like oh that's nice whatever man
welcome to the future coming fast
that might even be happening right now
we don't realize it like if the deep
state or like
you know the cia or like what else is
there boston dynamic these weird like
secret programs work because if we
if we we know that it's pretty advanced
if the public sees that
can we imagine the stuff that's been
worked on behind the scenes there were
pyramids
of pyramid-shaped objects flying over
u.s naval destruction but i heard they
couldn't find a base for these
pyramids so they're actually triangles a
base
they couldn't look like a pyramid has a
base to it so that means it's
three-dimensional but
i don't think they could see the
dimensions right so it's just triangles
right because they have gravitational
warp speed anything that you
you see publicly they got something way
better yeah yeah there's no so
we know confidential confidentiality
exists we know top secret exists
we know there is you know classification
so that means when you see like here's
our latest robot
well there are secret things you don't
know about wait so which side of the
culture were
are the aliens on then because we just
got a circle i would
i would honestly i was an anarchy
there's two schools of thought on this
um
the the aliens would be on the side of
the wok because
you look at like you've seen rick and
morty right yes
when the galactic federation takes over
earth everyone's forced to eat pills and
do menial labor for the sake of just
having a job
okay and so there's one i shouldn't say
there's two schools but one idea is that
they're on the side of the woke because
they need everyone to be drone-like and
ideologically homogeneous so this is a
one-world system
the galactic federation can't work with
the united states so long as there's
fractured nation states which would mean
the nationalists are certainly at odds
with
any alien and you know endeavor to
communicate with us because who would
they negotiate with
each different country get out of here
could you imagine if you were like we're
gonna go talk to russia and they had 10
presidents
you'd be like nah it's a waste of our
time get one president get out with it
what if they're interdimensional beings
though
well so the other idea but the other
idea is that they're anti-woke because
they're looking for
they're looking to work with those that
are intellect intellectually discerning
and can understand nuance and complex
thought and there's no point in engaging
with
drone-like species that's what i think i
mean i hope i guess a star trek future
with
of enlightenment values as opposed to
borg like values
you guys have a practice reference
psychic psychic energy
just like if we ever i would say out
there cosmic energy
cosmic energy tell me it's a different
thing i mean people pick up on
vibrations that's why i have the
mustache it's like
pick up on yeah it's attached to nerves
electromagnetic vibrations exactly
why do cats have whiskers they can sense
energy
exactly balance exactly yeah yeah like
apparently if you close things
off they like did you ever see those
wolves that like
they they line up to magnetic north and
they're fox i think foxes and then they
they hunt
but they'll like line up to magnetic
north and then they'll they'll like
sense the
the rabbit and then they'll dive and
catch it in the snow
that's interesting yeah dude i just know
for humans
uh because i read it in in thinking grow
rich and i think i've felt it a couple
times it's it's flow state yeah that's
like
that's like a normal thing for humans
it's it's it's you know like when you're
shredding the gnar
yeah shredding the knot i think it's you
cool your frontal lobes
it's almost i don't know it's just like
you're in an intense focus yeah
and i mean i felt it when i was work i
feel like i've i felt him even in some
of like the chaotic scenes but yeah oh
it's in a flow state
things just click it's just uh just one
of those
what do we used when i used to cover
riots
time slows down it's the greatest thing
ever yeah so people describe it as time
slowing down but i think i found a
better way to describe it at least for
me
it's not that time slowed down it kind
of feels that way like everything like
you can just
see everything and you're moving really
quick and you're dodging but to me i
think the easy way to explain it
is that when you're normally looking at
something you're focused on a single
point and you have peripheral vision
which is kind of out of focus and you
can kind of sort of understand
but for me when i'd be in a riot and
some high intensity thing would happen
my all of my vision would become the
same focus
like peripheral vision my whole field of
vision would become crystal clear and i
could see everything perfectly as if it
was not peripheral
and that i think simulated some kind of
time slowing down
because your brain is processing
everything really really fast and at
once
so it's like you're seeing everything
and then you can make a move
it kind of feels like time slowly that's
probably your flow state then tim
right it's like getting barrel brah
you're out there and then also you see
like someone raise a weapon pull a
trigger and then all of a sudden you're
just like well i told the
i mean i when i spoke to police after
the shooting i
basically all of my estimations on time
were way over
because i was like oh i think i
interviewed him yeah it was like 40
minutes and
maybe it was an hour it was 15 minutes
you know but there's so many things
leading up when you're
yeah i would think if time is a
perception of motion
then um if you're experiencing more
motion
then it would seem like less time was
happening
i wonder if it's actually the perception
of time is based upon the amount of
information you're processing
so if you're experiencing something that
you've experienced a million times
before your brain disregards it
and then time starts speeding up the
older you get because your brain is
ignoring
making the coffee in the morning it
doesn't register anymore when you're
younger making that coffee for the first
or tenth time it's like relatively new
so when you're in a conflict zone every
your brain is basically like
in this circumstance we must process any
and all process any and all information
that comes to us for the sake of our
safety
time feels like it's going slower
because your brain is running
all of these calculations and not
ignoring anything
so it's like actually i guess a better
way to put it is that's the true
experience of time
when all of the information is coming
into your brain and then the way we
normally experience time is there's gaps
because we forget things that don't
matter
that's why i like when i eat a big mac
it seems so quick exactly because your
brain doesn't care
many times that's why people can't
remember what that for breakfast it's
good it just happened so quick it's gone
but the first time you did a big thought
it was every bite takes
forever i still remember it yeah
no but like you asked people would you
have for breakfast yesterday and they'll
be like what did i ever
i can't remember because it is it
relevant yeah it's okay it's already
right
i bet i could ask you about what
happened in kenosha and you could
probably give me crazy details and
explain
all this crazy story you never for never
forget it that's that i mean that's a
very good point it's like
um i guess you know the amount of
details that stick out in your mind and
that was the interesting part too after
the fact is like
talking with the new york times
reporters and and stitching together all
these different streams and he's like
hey when you were running after kyle
like you stopped
like why did you stop there's something
fell on the ground and i was like
oh my god yeah i stopped because
my gas mask fell out of my bag because i
opened my gas mask bag
right before i saw kyle to break out a
white claw to defuse the situation with
these guys who wanted to smash my head
in
and so i didn't ever clip my gas mask
back in because i saw kyle running and
then i just ran after him
and you know like that kind of that kind
of stuff you don't forget
exactly but you forget what you had for
breakfast you know what i mean i mean
that figuratively like i don't know if
you remember what you have for breakfast
but
people forget like the little
nonsensical things that don't matter
but during that when you're in the fray
man everything is
sorry sorry that's why everyone said 20
20 went actually this is weird 20 i
guess this is why everyone said 2020
went by so fast
because we were all sitting in our
apartments doing the same thing over and
over and over again
so everybody was like wow i can't
believe how how you know how
i feel like 2020 was like six seven
years something really
yeah i i see a lot of people tweeting
he's not doing the same thing every day
already december i can't believe it's
already like whoa where did this where
did this year go
i guess depending on who you were
because for a lot of people they never
experienced pandemic before so
everything was new
for a lot of other people locked in
their apartments everything was
redundant
like solitary confinement would seem
like a million years right
yeah i don't know i don't know maybe it
just depends on the difference
on different people because i've heard
both i guess you lose track of time you
don't realize
some people overestimate some people
underestimate yeah
i don't know yeah like i kind of agree
with you richard i feel like 2020 lasted
longer than a year i guess just because
all the commotion that we were in and um
yeah i think another interesting thing
too is when you're on the ground
obviously you have you know the flow
state but
you start to actually pick up on a lot
of tendencies um i think they
they've used the word tendencies in
sports more but you start to pick up
tendencies on protesters
agitators law enforcement um just little
knickknacks that you already know kind
of
you know you can kind of predict some
things before they pop thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you